the holiday season is upon us but if
americans were hoping for a thanksgiving
feast or a christmas tree laden with
presents no luck a supply chain crisis
is this year's grinch bringing mass
shortages delivery delays and
record-breaking inflation
inflation hurts americans pocketbooks
and reversing this trend is a top
priority for me the largest share of the
increase in prices in this report is due
to rising energy costs so the president
with the tanking ratings and angry
voters has conveniently found the guilty
party energy and it's true that prices
have soared in fact a third of americans
had to skip or cut back on necessities
like food and medicine to pay their
energy bills in recent months you'd
think that wouldn't you that it wouldn't
be the best time to even talk about
shutting yet another pipeline
as we enter the winter months and
temperatures drop across the midwest the
termination of the michigan oil pipeline
will undoubtedly further exacerbate
shortages and price increases in home
heating fuels at a time when americans
are already facing rapidly rising energy
prices steep home heating costs global
supply shortages and skyrocketing gas
prices just the latest in a long line of
non-fans of biden's energy policy no
pipelines and no drilling permits
revoked and leases suspended the white
house has gone green even if it means
killing off thousands of jobs and
leaving your citizens to shiver but
instead of taking ownership for that
policy and the fallout now the president
and his people are pointing the finger
elsewhere oil is a global market it is
controlled by a cartel and they made a
decision yesterday that they were not
going to increase beyond what they were
already planning never mind that america
has enough supply in its own backyard to
churn out some barrels and bring down
those prices biden just won't turn on
the taps but opec should biden's not to
blame for a cold winter opec is biden's
not responsible for you struggling to
pay the bills opec is just as well he
explained it to us otherwise it's all
it's all quite complicated isn't it like
the supply chain oh well i'd explain it
to you but you just wouldn't understand
you hear a lot about the supply chains
in the news but frankly
not a lot of people are clear have a
clear understanding whether they have a
phd or they didn't go to school
about how a supply chain works
the blame game a classic in any
politicians playbook and perfect for
times of trouble you know like when your
party was humiliated in the recent
elections you're racing to be crowned
the least popular president in history
and now people can't even afford a warm
and cozy thanksgiving and you're not
even a year into your presidency
already home heating oil is up 59
percent and home gas heating is up 28
and it's going to get worse uh as the
winter comes here so uh some are
projecting some economists that the
uh heating costs uh for homes will
increase 100 percent
uh by the winter uh that's a big problem
that's going to cause uh you know a big
political uh backlash for biden
uh and i don't see what else
what much he can really do about it you
know he's talking about maybe opening
the petroleum reserves
uh but that's not gonna have much effect
because uh the problem is uh american
energy companies oil and gas companies
are exporting
uh a lot of this uh commodity and that's
giving them uh you know convenient
shortages here in eus that allows them
to boost their prices in the u.s so can
he stop them from exporting i doubt that
if he opens the petroleum reserve
you know they'll just use that and
export even more
you